professor Juan what would a forensic
photographer do upon entering a crime
scene document everything this is one of
my favorite topics first often I'm going
to have to look at you for this when you
have a camera you see on TV they hold it
straight ahead we don't do that in
forensics we hold the light off to the
side so it bounces this way angle of
incidence equals angle of reflection
I'll get out of your face now um that's
one of the things that gets me I
understand it's it's you know if they
flash bulb lights off it's going to
bounce holding something sideways as not
pointing towards the camera I get that
but in Rio forensics we we bounce
sideways otherwise the light will just
bounced straight back angle of incidence
equals angle of reflection really but
but refraction arm something else that i
would i would say about friends like
photographers that i was trained as is
shoot everything twice three times if
you can and that with digital you can if
you were originally if you remember
can't you know cameras carrying you know
35 pictures if you're going to film 10
10 rolls then shoot 15 you only get one
chance you only have so many some
limited amount of time to capture
everything and a good example the oj
trial there was a image that the
cameraman captured or the photographer
captured in the bathroom there were some
at the day of you know the actual crime
are the crime scene analysis there were
boxes of Swiss Army knives that were
like six inches long or something like
that they never saw those boxes own or
found those knives they only have the
pictures to go on so they couldn't move
any further but in the investigation it
came up they didn't go anywhere with it
in court I mean they try but they
couldn't go anywhere because all they
had were it was the image had he found
oh there's boxes of image stuff you have
to look you can't just take pictures go
okay
great what are you shooting what are you
taking images of so you have to look at
your surroundings your cataloguing the
entire thing now I don't mean take a
picture and write it down um we have
what's rebel four scales that we would
put down so that you can know okay you
know here's here's here's a ruler that
so you can know that this gun casing was
three inches long as compared to one
that's you know an inch and a half or
something like that so we have scales
and you put them down you take your
picture you pick it up you go somewhere
else um let's see what else what I do as
a photographer so document everything
document everything document everything
and you're not touching anything right
no because that's the medical examiner
no the medical examiner's for the body
the body okay they decedent the seton
excuse me okay i guess so but then this
forensic photographer is not touching
anything not moving anything it's
capturing the images as they are at this
well it's a conundrum which could come
in handy and variety if you find stuff
before the emmy gets there the medical
examiner take it your pictures document
everything then go through the house or
the crime scene again after the emmy has
removed the body and take pictures
because you may have to lift something
up there may be an inscription or
something there may be blood there may
be a bullet there may be something
hidden you know maybe it was an
organized offender and they have an mo
and they they're leaving their calling
card and you don't find it because you
didn't move things so yes you do want to
move things but not before the amy moves
the body that's only if there's a body
there's plenty of crimes you know
assault not assault by those humans
burglary breaking an entry home invasion
robberies all sorts of stuff were there
are no people involved and there's
plenty of crime breaking into a jewelry
store I remember when in Beverly Hills I
was trying to get down Wilshire and you
know they just document my friend ended
up documenting everything and they were
there all night documenting all the
jewelry because if they were missing a
piece the photographs would reveal with
that so what are some of the things that
a forensic photographer is taking
pictures up door knobs forced entry yes
wait we look at potential prints I mean
we talked about a finger prints earlier
they can take pictures of the prints too
you don't have to just lift them and and
get rid of them you can also take
pictures of particularly if you use the
fluorescence techniques you will use
lighting luminol I don't know if you're
male with luminol but blood that has
been washed away so you think can be
developed because of the proteins left
behind in the in the safes and the wall
if there was blood spatter on the wall
and people washed it down peroxide gets
blood out very nicely but it leaves the
fatty deposits behind so you may have
washed it down but you can use luminol
to redevelop the walls take pictures of
it because luminol will degrade over
time and disappear of course because
it's it's just it makes everything
luminess we use various oh okay here's
one here's ago we use various colors in
UV lights alternating light systems to
develop different pictures and be able
to see things you can see written hand
written articles on a piece of paper
where they had written on a piece of
paper above it and the paper is gone now
using a different light source and with
the right colored lens and you can also
see them with with goggles too and and
the right light source they have to be
matched if you will you know 100
micrograms and one other micrograms
eagles read whatever but you can make
you can see these things you can
photograph all of this stuff they did
that in
I can't remember misread your acne I was
red dragon again my favorite movie sorry
but they have great forensics in that
one when they're examining the toilet
paper from the crime scene and he had
blocked out blacked out I should say the
the address of a will Graham they took
they got everything squished down and
then use alternating light source to
make the pen that was underneath the
blackout come to the top if you will and
then take photographs of it and then
they had to put it back and get it back
in this in like Hannibal Lecter cell so
I mean that that's that's documented so
there's so many things like that a good
or even a bad forensic photographer can
do but the biggest thing is document
everything but we have two tips and
techniques to do things I'll leave you
with this one painting with white my
favorite technique you leave your camera
aperture open generally do do this with
two people you cover it and you say okay
I'm gonna I'm gonna light it up now they
uncover it and then you either shoot off
your flash or your strobe or you can
take one of those big Sun Sun lights and
literally paint with light and because
you're leaving the aperture open its and
we're talking like pitch black stuff you
can get a picture of a house which I've
done you can you can actually get a
picture of a house by painting with
light it's a fantastic technique I
highly look highly recommend that people
look into that
you